before we say goodbye we'd like to play
a quick round of truth or dare
all right we have allison st rock hi
hi hi allison hi so excited to be here
we're excited that you're here
all right what's it gonna be a truth or
a dare it's gonna be a dare a dare okay
you're down very much i get very few
dares thank you okay okay so i'm a tap
dancer oh
can i
show you a step and have you try it out
is it shuffle ball change it is not
yes i would be honored i took tap as a
kid you did
i didn't know this i wasn't good right
over here over here
i was not a good tap dancer but
there's always second chances in life
there is a shuffle in it oh okay oh you
even have tap shots
yes maybe
so the stuff is called a maxi forward
tap dancer staple um basically it's a
jump shuffle jump toe so the first part
is a jump just jump on your right foot a
shuffle on the left shuffle
jump back on the left
toe okay and then you can even add like
a little like pizzazz
oh
we will be jazz hats okay no problem
okay ready so then you can give it a
jump shuffle jump toe
like that right right okay one more time
one more time ready
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you to everybody again
you chose to spend your time with us we
are so grateful because we make this
show for you so
take it with you
[Music]
you